Hey sis!
Hey Jack!
Are you all excited for our trip?
Yeah!
And look what I found.
This is so cool!
Is this the same spot we're going to?
I hope so.
And look, I think that's where we're taking the boat tour!
Oh, I love it!
Look, I'm gonna go chat with Melissa but you're setting up the party room, right?
Yeah, I got it.
Thanks!
See you later, Jack.
Alright, see you later.
Bye!
Hey girl!
Guess what.
What?
I got the apartment.
Wow!
Nice!
Look at your balcony!
I know, it's amazing.
No roommates!
I have it all planned out.
The lucky blue couch.
Yes!
This table with this floor.
Perfect!
Jack keeps calling me.
Can we talk later?
Sure!
Bye!
Surprise!
Happy birthday!
Thanks, you guys!
Okay, hold this balloon.
You know we gotta do it.
Birthday selfie!
Don't forget your birthday hat.
Look at my birthday hat!
So cute!